So privacy's a good thing,
so do we have technologies that can
help enhance privacy or include privacy?
So here we're going to
talk about a few of those.
So one of the threats we talked
about was traffic analysis, okay?
You know who's talking to who,
so we said communication,
who I want to talk to.
Or if Alice is talking to Bob, somebody
else shouldn't be able to figure that
out and they could do that
with traffic analysis.
What machine is talking to what
other machine for source and
destination information.
So what if we don't want somebody
to be able to infer that?
So this we can do with this
technology called TOR,
and we'll see what exactly it does.
But it's basically sort of anonymous
communication is what we're trying to
get to here.
Let's say what's happening here is,
but Alice is, maybe interacting with
the website, but it doesn't want the
website to know that it's really Alice.
Or, doesn't even want to know,
this website to know, that, so
it's Bob's site is,
the website is operated by Bob.
So Alice doesn't want Bob's server to
know that the request is coming from
her, or even the IP address
from which it's coming.
So one way you can do that is,
Alice has a client, a TOR client.
So that fix a random path
the bunch of TOR nodes that
you need to find some set of those.
And it constructs this path in
such a way that any node here,
sort of knows about this predecessor and
its immediate successor, but
doesn't know who this request
has come through in the past, or
except its immediate successor, who is
the next node that's going to get it.
So this guy is told saying,
well just send it to the next node, and
the rest of the information,
the node after that,
that information is encrypted with this
node's key, so this guy would have no
idea that once it sends the message
here, it's going to go to this one.
Once it comes here, then it decrypts
that, the next destination, finds out.
And it doesn't know who it's
going to go after that, so
it doesn't have the full picture either.
So basically we create this
anonymous communication, or
implement anonymous communication
as TOR does, by using this kind of
a scheme where instead of nodes actually
forward the message repeatedly and
make use of encryption to sort of know
who the message is coming from, and
where it's going, and
that's all they know about.
They don't know the full path, and
as a result, traffic analysis,
no one is going to be able to figure out
that Alice is visiting Bob's website,
unless they have control
of all these nodes,
which the likelihood
of that would be less.